snapchat es el nuevo
sackler purdue sí, son los nuevos asesinos en masa
y
cómo consiguen estos niños estos
millones de píldoras falsas que han sido
enviadas a los estados unidos desde
méxico cómo las consiguen va
a ser a través de las redes sociales
aquí mi nombre es amy neville
y perdí a mi hijo alexander el 23 de junio de
2020 estamos llegando a dos años muy
rápidamente
aquí arriba
[música]
y encontramos a sammy muerto al día siguiente
gracias a snapchat
[música]
justo allí era un traficante de drogas en
Snapchat que se acercó a nuestro hijo con
el colorido menú de drogas
con
imágenes y colores y en la parte inferior
decía que entregó
y entonces
se conectó con nuestro hijo y entregó
las drogas a nuestra casa después de que estábamos
dormidos
[Música]
tú